tomorrow is Thanksgiving and we know the
celebration is going to start bright and
early for Mr Kevin Frazier yep Nichelle
I am co-hosting the Thanksgiving Day
Parade on CBS it's year number 12. we're
rehearsing today but I want to tell you
that straight up it is going to be a
celeb-filled celebration
Paul Abdul will belt out her classic
also performing the estefans including
Mama Gloria Dionne Warwick Jimmy Fallon
and The Roots and of course the queen of
Christmas Mariah Carey
[Music]
expect Broadway's best Leah Michelle and
the Gang from funny girl plus more music
from the cast of the new Pitch Perfect
series we're doing one of our classic
mashups 99 Luft balloons
mashed up with me
[Music]
any dancing involved I think some
dancing yeah as much as our giant coats
will allow us all right so let's break
down tomorrow's parade by the numbers
16 giant character helium balloons
newbies includes Stuart dominion and
Diary of a Wimpy Kid 28 floats five new
ones Ziggy Marley will sink his teeth
into baby shark and Jordin Sparks will
get down with Jeffrey's dazzling dance
party
5 000 volunteers 12 marching bands 10
performance groups and the estimated
crowd three million people are expected
to line the streets of New York Security
will be tight so they say arrive early
no later than 6 A.M
[Music]